koch instituts und dr rexroth des
leiterin des fachgebiets surveillance er
wieder zunächst guten morgen meine damen
und herren ich gebe ihnen zunächst einen
überblick über die kogit 19 pandemie
momentan wie sie in der welt rasant sich
weiterentwickelt weltweit sind mit dem
stand gestern 16,2 millionen fälle und
etwa 650 tausend todesfälle zu beklagen
das sind die zahlen die offiziell von
den einzelnen gesundheitseinrichtungen
gemeldet wurden
weltweit nehmen die täglich neu
gemeldeten fälle weiterhin zu und zwar
stark zu mehr als die hälfte der in den
letzten sieben tagen gemeldeten fälle
kommen allein aus nordamerika sowie
südamerikas in europa verzeichnen
besonders osteuropäische länder und die
balkanländer exponentielle anstiege in
west und südeuropa steigt der trend
ebenfalls an allerdings momentan
langsamer einige länder die die epidemie
bereits unter kontrolle zu haben
schienen verzeichnen erneut zunehmenden
fallzahlen wie zb australien japan oder
auch spanien ausschlag geben
in diesen ländern ist das die
individuellen schutzmaßnahmen nicht mehr
so gut befolgt werden vor allen dingen
unter jüngeren menschen aber auch in
unterschiedlichen formen von
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen und familien
zusammenkünften sowie auch bei saison
arbeitenden ein gemeinsamer trend der
letzten woche ihr weltweit sind die
wiedereinführung von maßnahmen auf
lokaler ebene
so haben wir zum beispiel einen erneuten
lockdown in einigen städten in marokko
oder eine verschärfung der masken
pflicht etwa in österreich und
frankreich
fazit meine damen und herren wir sind
mitten in einer sich rasant
entwickelnden pandemie
ein kurzer vergleich zwischen einigen
ländern und dem stand in deutschland
weltweit vergleicht deutschland stand 28
2 siebter mit ländern und der stand ist
vom 27 07 10 uhr
wir haben einige länder herausgesucht
die viele von ihnen kennen werden einige
von ihnen werden diese vielleicht sogar
schon bereist haben den letzten jahren
vereinigte staaten
dort sind offiziell und 4,2 3 4
millionen menschen mit kuwait 19
infiziert gemeldet worden
und was hier besonders bedrückend ist
ist die tatsache dass allein in den
letzten sieben tagen mehr als 460.000
neue fälle gemeldet wo in den
vereinigten staaten von amerika sind
bislang offiziell 147.000 todesfälle im
zusammenhang mit kurven 19 gemeldeten
brasilien ein weiteres land das wirklich
schrecklich von kuwait 19 zurzeit
heimgesucht wird dort sind insgesamt 2,4
19 millionen fälle offiziell gemeldet
worden
und auch hier ist die entwicklung den
letzten wochen rasant in den letzten
sieben tagen mehr als 320.000 neue fälle
in brasilien sind bislang offiziell
87.000 toten viktor 19 tote gemeldet
worden indien
sie erinnern sich vielleicht an den
beginn dieser pandemie als auch in die
nur sehr wenige infektionen gemeldet
wurde inzwischen ist die zahl auf 1,4
millionen gestiegen
und auch hier hat in den letzten sieben
tagen eine rasante entwicklung
stattgefunden
mehr als 300 17.000 neue fälle in den
letzten sieben tagen
die zahl der dort gemeldeten offiziell
gemeldeten toten beläuft sich momentan
auf 32.800 oder südafrika das sich als
letztes land nennen möchte insgesamt
mehr als 440.000 fell gemeldet auch hier
davon allein mehr als 81.000 allein in
den letzten sieben tagen
und hier sind offiziell 6800 todesfälle
zu beklagen
schauen wir uns deutschland an so haben
wir mit dem stand 0 uhr 200 6242
offizielle fall meldungen über die
gesundheitsämter gemeldet bekommen aber
auch in deutschland müssen wir leider
feststellen und das ist der grund des
heutigen presse briefings dass wir eine
zunehmende fallzahl haben in den letzten
wochen und zwar in den letzten sieben
tagen 3611 fälle in deutschland und wir
haben insgesamt 9000 122 tote im
zusammenhang mit 19 zu beklagen die zahl
der chinesen in deutschland schätzen wir
momentan auf etwas mehr als 190.000 das
heißt das sind diejenigen menschen die
nach einer schätzung die akute
infektionskrankheit überstanden haben
wenn darunter die neueste entwicklung in
deutschland die neueste entwicklung der
kogit 19 pfalz an die macht mir und die
macht uns allen im robert-koch-institut
große sorgen wir hatten es ja alle
geschafft die fallzahlen über mehrere
wochen stabil zu halten
ende juni anfang juli wurden dem
robert-koch-institut nur noch rund 300
bis 500 fälle täglich übermittelt auch
die zahl der täglich übermittelten
todesfälle war zwischenzeitlich deutlich
gesunken
das ist ein großer erfolg
und dieser erfolg zeigt uns dass wir das
virus eindämmen können
aber das gelingt uns nur wenn wir uns an
die regeln halten meine damen und herren
aber seit einigen tagen sehen wir dass
die fallzahlen wieder deutlich steigen
zur entwicklung der fallzahlen wird
ihnen jetzt meine kollegin ute rexroth
mehr details geben damit sie die zahlen
wirklich gut einordnen können und
rexroth ist eine der leiterinnen des
lagezentrums am robert koch institut das
seit mitte januar aktiviert ist bei ihr
laufen die fäden und informationen
zusammen vorweg
vielen dank herr villa also ich möchte
ihnen das was er wieder gesagt hat jetzt
noch einmal mit einigen abbildungen
illustrieren die ich hoffe sie dann
sehen können
die sollen die fallzahlen in deutschland
eben speziell in den letzten paar wochen
auch verdeutlichen
sie finden die zahlen und die abbildung
natürlich in unserem lagebericht und auf
dem dashboard das heißt wenn sie die
jetzt nicht sehen können dann können sie
da auch eben mal reinschauen sollten sie
am computer sitzen und denken sie bitte
immer daran diese zahlen sind nicht der
aktuelle stand das ist nicht heute
sondern es ist das was bei uns ankommt
das hat immer einen gewissen melde
verzug und eine übermittlung verzug
also es spiegelt die lage vor ein paar
tagen wieder so die erste abbildung die
ich ihnen zeigen möchte ist die
epidemische kurve nach melde datum die
kennen sie ja bereits letztes mal hatten
wir die kurve nach erkrankungsbeginn die
etwas besser zeigt ja wann sind denn die
leute erkrankt aber dieses mal möchte
ich ihnen die kurve nach melde datum
zeigen weil das auch deutlicher zeigt
wie die fallzahlen bei uns eingehen sie
sehen da sehr starke säbelsäge zahn
muster nennen wir das das sind artefakte
das ist weil die menschen am wochenende
nicht so viel getestet werden und am
wochenende nicht so viel übermittelt
wird
aber man kann trotzdem wirklich gut
sehen dass wir im märz und april extrem
viele fälle pro tag hatten mehrere
tausend und bis über 6000 pro tag ist
das gegangen und das ist sehr deutlich
zurückgegangen also im ganzen diese
kurven ganzen betrachtet zeigt ein
erfolg sie sehen auch mitte ende juni
noch mal kleinen anstieg das war das
hauptsächlich auf das geschehen in
gütersloh zurückzuführen also große
ausbruchsgeschehen die dann die kurve
auch deutschlandweit etwas verändert
haben aber insgesamt ist es uns gelungen
auch im vergleich zu anderen ländern und
alle als gesellschaft als bevölkerung
diese am fallzahlen deutlich zu
reduzieren und das ist natürlich ein
ein großer erfolg in dem nächsten in der
nächsten abbildung möchte ich ihnen aber
die letzten zwei wochen noch mal zeigen
wie das in den letzten zwei wochen
ausgesehen hat und hier sehen sie auch
wieder blau die berichtigten für
berichteten fälle und auch wieder hier
diesen sägezahn dieses muster was
wochenende in orange sehen sie die fälle
die uns jetzt heute noch gemeldet und
sind und die sind nach melde datum drauf
sortiert worden da sieht man es gibt
einen gewissen verzug
aber ja nicht so hoch aber man sieht
eben auch dass es in den letzten zwei
wochen wieder mehr geworden ist der
trend nimmt wieder zu
und das war 16 juli lagen die fälle eben
davor lang die immer bei ungefähr 500
oder darunter und jetzt am freitag da
haben wir uns wirklich sorgen gemacht
815 neue fälle freitag sind immer die
meisten fälle aber das war schon viel am
samstag auf 781 neue fälle am sonntag
305 gestern 340 und heute wieder 633
neue fälle also es ist doch deutlich
mehr und das geschehen ist
deutschlandweit es ist nicht nur ein
einzelnes geschehen sondern es ist
wirklich ein deutschlandweites geschehen
und das möchte ich ihnen zeigen in der
abbildung 3
da sehen wir den trend der sieben tages
incidents nach bundesländern also wie
verhält sich das in den bundesländern
die sieben tages instanzen die
kumulativen 7 tages instanzen je 100.000
bevölkerung und die etwas dickere orange
linie die zeigt den gesamtverlauf höher
ganz deutschland da sind wir jetzt zum
schluss bei 43 es gibt einige
bundesländer die noch deutlich darüber
liegen das ist nordrhein-westfalen zum
beispiel das halb acht aber auch bayern
berlin mit über 5 bremen hamburg hessen
also hamburg ist genau im
bundesdurchschnitt und sie sehen an
diesen verschiedenen bund farbigen
linien sie werden sie vielleicht nicht
richtig zuordnen können war es etwas
schwierig aber wir möchten damit nur
zeigen dass es wirklich viele
bundesländer betrifft das ist nicht nur
ein bundes
etwas durch ein großes
ausbruchsgeschehen hier hervorsticht
nicht nur ein landkreis sondern es sind
wirklich leider viele betroffen
und das sehen sie auch wieder in der
nächsten abbildung der karte
das ist jetzt von unserem dashboard
diese karte genommen und da sehen sie
diese kumulativen 7 tages incidence also
was ist in den letzten sieben tagen
gemeldet worden
landkreis und da sieht man eben sehr gut
in der geographischen verteilung in
einzelnen und treiben deutlicher vor
poppen jetzt hier rot dargestellt
wenn das über 50 je 100000 ist das ist
jetzt aktuell dingolfing landau in
bayern auch auffällig ist hof der
bayerische landkreis hof und auch weimar
in thüringen die zwar deutlich weniger
aber auch über 25 400 tausend fälle
jetzt berichten
in den letzten 7 tagen sie sehen aber
auch dass das gesamte hintergrund
geschehen also auch viele andere
landkreise wieder betroffen sind
wir hatten zwischenzeitlich den fall
dass über 150 landkreise in den letzten
sieben tagen glaube ich fast 150 landrat
letzten sieben tagen keine fälle
gemeldet haben und jetzt ist das schon
deutlich zurück gegangen das sind jetzt
nur noch 95 fälle also vor 14 tagen war
1915 und dieses geschehen das macht uns
eben wirklich sorge das ist diffus
es ist nicht nur ein einzelnes geschehen
ist es handelt sich um fall anstiege in
ganz ganz vielen unterschiedlichen
kommunen und gemeinden und da steckt
also dass da sieht man dass ich in
deutschland
deutschlandweit wieder mehr leute
menschen mit diesem virus anstecken was
wirklich gefährlich ist ja was sind das
für settings wo finden diese übertragung
stadt man muss sagen ist das so wirklich
überall es kann wirklich überall sein
was wir mitkriegen was uns berichtet
wird sind familienfeiern hochzeiten
treffen mit freunden
das sind aber auch ausbrüche am
arbeitsplatz und
gemeinschaftsunterkünften auch in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen
das sind leider auch pflegeeinrichtungen
das sind altenheime und auch
einrichtungen des gesundheitswesens wo
wir natürlich besonders viel sorge haben
wenn das einrichtungen des
gesundheitswesens betrifft und ja weil
man da auch besonders viele schwere
verläufe dann erwarten muss leider und
das ist sehr sehr gut gelungen gewesen
dass zurückzudrängen und wir haben eben
jetzt diese sorge dass es wieder
ansteigen könnte es kann auch schnell
gehen es kann auch wirklich schnell
wieder ansteigen das sehen wir an den
anderen ländern
es sind natürlich auch reiserückkehrer
wieder mehr dabei also es gibt mehr
fälle die im ausland exponiert waren
aber der weitaus größte teil hat sich
tatsächlich in deutschland angesteckt
und es gilt jetzt diese ausbreitung
diese übertragungen in deutschland
weiter konsequent einzugrenzen
wir haben gesehen und alle zusammen
gezeigt dass das geht und das muss uns
auch weiter gelingen wir haben die sorge
dass das eine trendumkehr andeuten
könnte und es liegt in unserer hand das
zu vermeiden und hier ist prävention auf
jeden fall besser als reaktion bykow
wird 19 läuft man den ausbrüchen auf
jeden fall hinterher und kann gar nicht
so eifrig man auch ist schnell genug
sein um alle fälle wieder einzufangen
und alle kontakte zu ermitteln
deswegen müssen sie alle hier gemeinsam
weiterhin ganz stark auf prävention
achten
danke sehr vor rexroth also meine damen
und herren diese entwicklung ist
wirklich sehr beunruhigend wir sehen
viele kleine ausbrüche die an
verschiedenen orten gleichzeitig
auftreten und wir sehen dass diese
ausbrüche häufiger werden wir müssen
jetzt verhindern dass das virus sich
wieder rasant ausbreitet dass es sich
unkontrolliert ausbreitet und das
schaffen wir nur gemeinsam
ich habe an dieser stelle mehrfach von
der studie
cosmo gesprochen und einige daten
vorgestellt das ist eine zunächst
wöchentliche inzwischen zwei
wöchentliche befragung die das robert
koch institut unter anderem mit der
universität er foto führt und diese
studie gibt das stimmungsbild in der
bevölkerung wieder das ist ein sehr
wichtiger parameter für unseren immer
die messe die entsprechenden messages
anzupassen
die neuesten ergebnisse zeigen dass das
virus von der bevölkerung als ein
geringeres risiko angesehen wird als
zuvor und das auch die akzeptanz von
maßnahmen wie der rh regel weiter
gesunken ist
ich möchte an dieser stelle noch einmal
ganz deutlich machen
wir haben es wirklich zum großteil
selber in der hand wie sich die pandemie
in deutschland weiterentwickeln wird
bitte helfen sie alle weiter mit bitte
halten sie sich weiterhin an die aha
regeln und die möchte ich noch mal
ausführen
halten sie abstand mindestens ein meter
fünfzig beachten sie die hygiene regeln
und tragen sie in bestimmten situationen
zusätzlich zu diesen beiden maßnahmen
einen mund nasen bedeckung und ich bitte
sie auch alle diesem unten nasen
bedeckung richtig zu tragen das heißt
also über mund und nase und diese regel
meine damen und herren die gelten auch
im freien
sie gelten überall egal wo sie sind auch
wenn sie im urlaub sind und wenn sie
sich in räumen aufhalten lüften sie
bitte regelmäßig
wir haben in den vergangenen monaten in
deutschland wirklich sehr viel erreicht
wir haben dafür eine menge auch geopfert
wir haben damit die pandemie bislang im
vergleich zu vielen anderen ländern sehr
gut gemeistert
dank der verschiedensten maßnahmen und
dank der großartigen leistung der
gesundheitsämter der kliniken der
arztpraxen labor und vieler vieler
menschen und natürlich dank all der
menschen also dank uns allen die wir uns
an die regeln und empfehlungen gehalten
haben sie wir alle haben dazu
beigetragen dass die fallzahlen gesunken
sind
dass weniger menschen schwer krank
geworden sind als wir das ursprünglich
befürchteten dass das gesundheitssystem
nicht überlastet worden ist und auch
dass weniger menschen gestorben sind als
befürchtet
das ist ein erfolg und diesen erfolg den
haben wir gemeinsam in den ersten
monaten dieser pandemie erreicht
aber diesen erfolg gilt es
kontinuierlich weiter zu sichern
wir sollten unseren erfolg feiern ja
aber wir dürfen uns nicht auf diesem
erfolg ausruhen damit das virus sich
nicht wieder beginnt rasant zu
verbreiten damit es nicht außer
kontrolle gerät
wie schnell das passieren kann meine
damen und herren das zeigen die
erfahrungen aus anderen ländern
nehmen wir zum beispiel israel dass die
pandemie ausgezeichnet im griff hat und
nun eine wirklich schweren rückfall hat
und dort ist das virus momentan nicht
mehr unter kontrolle
ich weiß auch natürlich dass die
vergangenen monate ihnen allen viel
abverlangt haben und wie alle wünsche
ich dass die pandemie vorbei wäre
aber meine damen und herren sie ist
nicht vorbei wir sind mittendrin in
dieser pandemie die ganze welt ist
mittendrin in dieser partie lassen sie
uns erreichen dass möglichst wenig
menschen erkannten und wir möglichst
wenige durch das virus verlieren das ist
möglich gemeinsam können wir das
erreichen und jede einzelne von uns kann
viel dazu beitragen dass meine damen und
herren das gibt mir sehr viel hoffnung
danke sehr
vielen dank jetzt besteht die
möglichkeit fragen zu stellen und wir
fangen an mit planet interview herr
bohrer hallo wenn sie mich ja wir hören
sie gut ich hab zum briefing an sich
also sie haben jetzt einmal im monat des
brüchigen gemacht dass es gibt einmal im
monat 45 minuten die möglichkeit fragen
zu stellen halten sie es für machbar
unter den aktuellen umständen das
briefing häufiger wieder stattfinden zu
lassen und die zweite frage wie denkt
dass er jetzt über die und neue
schulsachen nach empfehlen sie
möglicherweise was weiß ich die
schulpflicht auszusetzen
er hat den dank für die frage also zur
ersten frage
das briefing wird anlassbezogen
stattfinden momentan planen wir keine
regelmäßige briefing sondern wir denken
dass es sinnvoll ist anlassbezogen das
briefing durchzuführen zur zweiten frage
die öffnung der schulen ist ein ganz
wichtiges thema das uns alle in den
letzten wochen intensiv beschäftigt die
schulen werden geöffnet und sie müssen
auch geöffnet werden
aber sie müssen geöffnet werden unter
bestimmten regeln und ist nun die
aufgabe derjenigen die dafür
verantwortlich sind diese pläne regeln
auszuarbeiten und dann durchzuführen das
heißt wir erwarten bestimmte hygiene
konzepte für gestalten wir erwarten
bestimmte epidemiologische konzepte die
im kern zu folgende führen müssen
es darf nicht dazu kommen dass sich die
schüler alle irgendwie in den pausen und
beim wie zuzufügen auch von den schulen
eben zu der mission
es müssen einheiten gebildet werden die
möglichst gemeinsam bleiben und sich
nicht mit anderen einheiten vermischen
eines müssen wir ganz klar verstehen der
grund warum das virus sich ausbreiten
kann ist ja der dass menschen
zusammenkommen dann teilweise eben sich
nicht an die regeln halten wenn einer
von den personen die unter 100 personen
zum beispiel sind das virus trägt und
zehn andere ansteckt dann tragen diese
zehn anderen das wieder weiter in ihrer
familie
und dann werden sie ihre eltern und ihre
großeltern mit diesem virus infizieren
können
das heißt das ist die ganz klassische
maßnahme dass man dafür sorge trägt dass
leute nicht zu viel zu eng zusammen
kommen und dann nicht sich in viele
andere settings wieder begeben und das
ist die aufgabe derjenigen die dafür
sorge zu tragen haben da gibt es
rahmenkonzepte die sind ja auch vom
robert koch institut publiziert worden
aber die umsetzung dieser maßnahmen
obliegt natürlich den schulen und den
ämtern vor ort und diese maßnahmen
müssen natürlich auch beinhalten dass
man wenn krankheiten auftreten diese
möglichst schnell erkennt und dann die
person die positiv erkrankt sind
wahrscheinlich erkrankt sind als die
klinisch symptomatisch sind auch schnell
testen kann
das sind alles dinge die man planen kann
und wir erwarten dass die zuschuss zahlt
auch dann am start sind
vielen dank wir gehen zu reuters
erwartet
ja meine frage wäre soll es bei dem
bisherigen konzept bleiben dass man halt
regional reagiert auf ausbrüche sie
sagten ja eben eigentlich ist jetzt
praktisch deutschlandweit da muss man
weder stärkere in deutschland weiter
regeln eines schön weil man zum beispiel
urlaubsrückkehrer aber nicht so genau
eingrenzen kann also der der wesentliche
punkt ist der dass natürlich immer lokal
bekämpft wird das ist von anfang an zu
gewesen das ist der job der
gesundheitsämter und er wird auch so
bleiben
entscheidend ist dass möglichst wenig
ausbrüche vor ort auftreten und dann
kann man das selbstverständlich lokal
beherrschen und das tun die
gesundheitsämter auch nur wenn es zu
viele ausbrüche sind wenn es eine so
genannte community transmission gibt das
heißt also eine unkontrollierte
ausbreitung des virus eben nicht
gebunden an einzelne ausbrüche sondern
wenn man mehrere fälle hat die man nicht
mehr gut zuordnen kann
dann wird quasi die maßnahme lokal
verbreitert aber der kern ist die
bekämpfung durch die gesundheitsämter
vor ort und noch mal mein appell
das alles geschieht nur weil wir
menschen uns nicht mehr an diese regeln
halten wenn wir das tun dann wird es
nicht zu diesen ausbrüchen können also
wir haben das wirklich zum großen teil
in
hand zumindest der mehrheit der
bevölkerung bei manchen sind die arbeits
oder lebenssituation vielleicht so dass
sie das nicht so können wieder viele
andere können wir alle die dies können
die sollten es tun und es ist einfach
wirklich rücksichtslos und auch
fahrlässig wenn man wilde partys feiert
zum beispiel in irgendwelchen
großstädten und vielleicht sogar zu
tausenden
doch zusammen ist dann steigt die chance
dass von diesen quellen aus infektionen
verbreitet werden denn auch wenn das zum
beispiel alles junge menschen sein mögen
die statistische wahrscheinlichkeit
weniger schwer erkranken
diese menschen können aber das virus in
ihre familien tragen
sie können damit ihre eltern ihnen
verzieren sie können damit ihre
großeltern infizieren und genauso gut
können natürlich unter diesen menschen
auch solche sein die in pflegeheimen
arbeiten oder in krankenhäusern arbeiten
und damit können sie das virus dann in
diese einzelnen settings übertragen also
nochmal der entscheidende punkt und der
grund warum wir so gut waren in den
letzten monaten war dass wir uns an die
regeln gehalten wenn wir das tun dann
können wir das virus in schach
wenn wir das nicht tun wenn wir den
virus die chance geben sich zu vermehren
zu vervielfältigen das tun wir nur wenn
wir ihm die chance zu geben das sich von
einem menschen auf den anderen
übertragen werden kann und dort vor
vielfalt die dort dann wird es
problematisch
wir gehen zur nächsten agentur s p hat
schreiber sie dazu bewegen das oft
gerieten projekt nun ohne dies so was in
erwägung
das ist eine sehr gute frage scheiber
dankeschön dafür also ich möchte
zunächst klarstellen dass die
risikogebiete zusammen vom
außenministerium vom auswärtigen amt dem
bundesministerium für gesundheit und
inneren erstellt wird das heißt diese
drei institutionen legen fest was ein
risikogebiet ist und was eines nicht ist
das robert koch institut
zeichnet diese risiko biete dann aus auf
seiner website aber wir legen nicht fest
was ein risikogebiet ist oder nicht
es gibt verschiedene kennzahlen die eine
kennzahl die wirklich wichtig ist es die
der inzidenz und sieben tage in sidenten
50 mehr als 50 pro 100000 das ist die
erste kennzahl die man erfahren kann
anhand der meldesysteme der einzelnen
ländern aber darüber hinaus werden vor
ort insbesondere vom auswärtigen abend
die ja in allen ländern natürlich sitzen
und dort informationen sammeln können
hochwertige informationen von ihren
diensten sammeln können dort werden
verschiedene situationen betrachtet gibt
es community ausbrüche gibt es nur
lokale ausbrüche in welchen regionen
trifft das auf das heißt also das ist
eine liste von verschiedenen indikatoren
die dann letztlich dazu führen wird ob
ein gebiet zum risikogebiet erklärt wird
oder nicht
und ich darf ihnen sagen dass natürlich
alle länder auf der welt kontinuierlich
monitor werden also alle länder werden
immer angeschaut und wenn dann bestimmte
parameter überschritten sind und das
risiko als hoch eingeschätzt
dann wird das zu einem risikogebiet
ernannt von diesen drei ministerien und
dann wird das unter anderem auch beim
robert-koch-institut auf die website
gesetzt damit sie menschen sie
informieren können aber
selbstverständlich hat auch das
auswärtige amt die entsprechenden listen
auf ihrer website
vielen dank
wir gehen zu bild dank der geschickten
zweiten welle können sie das in dem so
kann man auch mal einschätzen und als
nachfrage dazu sind die aus ihrer sicht
auch oder also wir wissen das natürlich
nicht ob das der beginn einer möglichen
zweiten welle ist aber er kann es
natürlich sein
es würde ja mit steigenden an zahlen das
wäre der der der beginn wenn man im
nachhinein drüber schoss
ich bin nach wie vor optimistisch dass
wenn wir uns alle an diese aha
wir halten dass wir das verhindern
können darum nochmal ganz klar mein
appell an uns alle wir können das
verhindern es liegt wirklich an uns das
zu tun
das heißt also diese regeln dass er auch
noch mal eine gute frage vorbei diese
regeln werden wir noch monatelang
einhalten müssen ja diese müssen also
der standard sein die dürfen überhaupt
nie hinterfragt werden abstand halten
händehygiene und dort wo wir abstand
nicht halten können zusätzlich alltags
masken oder mund nasen schutz tragen und
das gilt für drinnen und draußen also
das ist die grundregel die dürfte und
sollte niemand mehr infrage stellen das
sollten wir einfach so tun
ja und dann ist es halt so wenn es
trotzdem zu lokalen ausbrüchen kommt und
es trotzdem zu größeren ausbrüchen kommt
dann kommen natürlich die lokalen
maßnahmen dazu das kann dazu führen dass
man lokal wieder bestimmte ortschaften
schließt das man lokal dazu führt dass
man gaststätten schließt dass man
bestimmte maßnahmen die man gelockert
haben dass man diese maßnahmen wieder
anzieht aber das ist noch mal das ist
wirklich der entscheidende grund warum
wir so viel wert darauf legen dass die
gesundheitsämter gestärkt werden warum
auch dieses maßnahmenpaket für die
gesundheitsämter geschürt wird damit die
ausdrücklich schnell erkannt werden
damit viel getestet wird das mir fälle
schnell erkennen dass wir aus
blutuntersuchungen schnell erkennen dass
wir menschen schnell in quarantäne
schicken
da sind ja alles nur aber reaktive
maßnahmen und die müssen natürlich so
gut wie möglich durchgeführt werden wir
haben die tests kapazität enorm erhöht
wir haben diesen trend unterstützt und
so weiter und so fort aber das sind
alles nur reaktive maßnahmen wir wollen
die proaktive maßnahmen wie
präventionsmaßnahmen und das sind die
haarige wir gehen zum deutschlandfunk
volkart wildermuth danke ich wollte noch
mal fragen sie haben die community
ausbreitung erwähnt ist das jetzt sind
sind wir dem stadium wo es einzeln der
ausbrüche überall sind oder ist das
schon eine breite gruppe die ausbreitung
dann die frage sie haben schon zu
dämlich füllen gesprochen wie sieht es
aus mit anderen bereichen also die leute
kommen aus dem urlaub zurückrief ja die
arbeiten muss jeder betrieb jede konzept
entwickeln
die sitzungspräsidenten noch weitere
schwer
ausgetragen also momentan sehen wir in
deutschland noch keine community
transmission
das heißt also wir haben eben wirklich
die chance dass einzelne sind momentan
noch ausbrüche kleine ausbrüche es ist
nicht so dass jeder fall komplett
nachvollzogen werden kann leider aber
wir haben zurzeit noch nicht die
situation dass war community ausbrüche
haben aber er will mode ihre frage zu
den konzepten in den betrieben
also ganz ehrlich ich gehe natürlich
davon aus dass diese konzepte schon seit
monaten laufen dass das das alltag ist
das eine ist ja diese regelung da wo das
möglich ist das home office eine große
rolle spielt dadurch verringert man eben
die kontaktmöglichkeit dadurch
verringert man also die chance dass ein
virus von einem möglichst infizierten
mitarbeiter auf den anderen überspringen
und diese maßnahmen werden wir auch
monatelang noch in allen betrieben haben
das gehört ja für mich auch damit zu den
maßnahmen die wir fahren also die aha
reden sind ja die persönlichen die
individuellen maßnahmen die für jeden
bundesbürger geld und alle 83 millionen
haben sich daran zu halten wenn es
irgendwie geht aber darüber hinaus haben
wir natürlich konzepte in betrieben und
es gibt betriebe die das fantastisch
machen ja es gibt betriebe die schon
sehr früh solche konzepte eingefahren
haben und die müssen eben in fleisch und
blut übergehen und weiter so durchlaufen
und auch unabhängig von der epidemische
lage das ist der entscheidende punkt
glaube ich auch dieser dieses presse
briefings nochmal diese maßnahmen müssen
wir alle halten weil wir dem virus songs
die chance geben wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen
und obwohl wir in deutschland teilweise
ganz gute zahlen hatten leider hatten
wir nie stabil unter 300 das muss man
auch sagen das war eine hoffnung die ich
persönlich hatte dass wir kontinuierlich
unter 300 butter kommen hat nur nicht
aber obwohl wir so niedrig waren sehen
wir jetzt für den anstieg und der
anstieg hängt ja nur damit zusammen dass
wir nachlässig geworden sind und das
gilt für den das individuum und das gilt
natürlich für alle betriebe
das gilt für zu hause genossen
vielen dank wir gehen zur stuttgarter
zeitung herr plan wetzig hallo hört man
mich ja wir haben wunderbar
vielen dank herr wille ich hab' ich habe
zwei fragen
also ja berlin ja an die an die
bevölkerung sich mehr an die regenzeit
das hat ja auch mit der akzeptanz mit
der ist sagen lage einschätzung sind wir
in einer neuen krise oder ist oder nicht
zum einen kommt da ganz auf das argument
na ja es wird ja auch ganz viel getestet
derzeit also finde ich auch ganz viele
infektionen vielleicht können sie da zu
machen sagt sagen
und zum zweiten die die ausbrüche über
diese sprechen die vielen lokalen
ausbrüche kann man die den zähnen kann
man das quantifizieren weil es ist jetzt
endlich der einschätzung was als in der
einschätzung wir haben gerade viele
ausbrüche aber können sie die können sie
die zellen können sie sagen die anzahl
der ausbrüche ist stark gestiegen
zuletzt also wie messen sieht es ja klar
also danke schön für die frage also die
die das können wir zählen ja frau
rexroth hat ihn einige ausbrüchen dann
natürlich betrachten wir jeden einzelnen
ausbruch und wir sind auch mit vielen
gesundheitsämtern in kontakt es ist ja
auch immer die frage ob das
gesundheitsamt die ausbrüche selber
kontrollieren kann oder ob zum beispiel
das robert koch institut und auch wieder
andere amtshilfe gegeben werden kann wo
man größere ausbrüche einnehmen kann
da ist ja sehr viel flexibilität in den
letzten monaten gewachsen ja wir können
die ausbrüche zählen selbstverständlich
das ist ja einer unsere jobs und wir
spiegeln die ausbrüche natürlich auch
zurück an die gesundheitsämter damit sie
auch wissen was in anderen landkreisen
in der umgebung unterwegs ist und sehr
häufig hängen ausbrüche ja auch die
lokal unterschiedlich sind aber da
dadurch zusammen dass zum beispiel
menschen auf einer familienfeier
zusammengekommen sind auf hochzeiten
die reisen dann ja an aus ganz
deutschland und und können dann den
ausbruch jahr in andere teile bringen
ja das können wir die erste frage war
die der testung ja das ist richtig
die testung ist natürlich wichtig und je
mehr wir testen desto mehr fälle werden
wir auch finden aber sie müssen eines da
immer im blick haben
wir veröffentlichen einen
situationsbericht ich glaube ist das
mittwochs oder donnerstags diese testen
donnerstags glaube ich oder mehr
mittwochs mittwochs publizieren wir in
dem im situationsbericht der immer wie
viel test durchgeführt wurden und wir
produzieren in dem zusammen auch immer
wie viel tests positiv waren
und sie sehen natürlich je mehr wir
testen desto geringer ist dann die
positiven rate das heißt also ein das
verhältnis von tests insgesamt zu rate
der positiven ist für uns auch ein
wichtiger indikator um herauszufinden
wie viele menschen wirklich in unserem
land infiziert sind wir können daraus
natürlich schätzungen durchführen und
dann wissen wir ja auch und das auch ein
wichtiger punkt wir wissen ja auch warum
zb viel getestet wird nehmen wir jetzt
mal als beispiel den ausbruch in
gütersloh der der größte ausbruch von
denen wir bislang in der ganzen partie
in unserem land hatten in diesem
zusammenhang da waren mehr als 1500
menschen infiziert in diesem
zusammenhang wurde natürlich viele
tausend in der umgebung auch getestet
und diese testung nehmen weder natürlich
mit in unsere betrachtung hinein also
wir betrachten nicht nur die reinen
zahlen sondern dadurch dass wir uns
einzelne geschehen besonders anschauen
haben wir auch ein gutes gefühl dazu und
eine abschätzung was diese zahlen
wirklich bedeuten
das ist etwas was wir auch im blick
haben müssen das ist auch unser job und
das tun wir natürlich ja vielen dank
keine weiteren fragen mehr es war ja
auch nicht so kompliziert mit den aha
regeln
da kommt noch eine frage dann gehen wir
zur tagesschau frau hahn
hallo frau haben können sie uns auch so
können sie uns hören sie mich ja guten
morgen und aber noch einmal eine frage
zu den reiserückkehrern frau rexroth
sagte ja dass sie nicht so eine große
rolle spielen können sie das ein
bisschen quantifizieren welche rolle die
spielen ob die zahlen zu nehmen und ob
sie da große befürchtungen haben und man
nicht gerne direkt antworten frau hahn
ja also die nehmen auf jeden fall wieder
zu uns kommen bisschen darauf an was wir
als bezugsgröße betrachten
am anfang der pandemie war natürlich ein
großer anteil der fälle reise assoziiert
und das ist dann gegen null fast
gegangen klar das ist sind ja fast keine
reisen mehr haben wir fast keine reisen
mehr stattgefunden und jetzt in den
letzten wochen sehen wir dass das wieder
zunimmt
also wenn das auf alle fälle betrachten
dann ist es so um die zehn prozent wenn
wir es bei denjenigen die eine angabe
zum exposition zum wahrscheinlichen
exposition zu ort betrachten das ist so
um die 18 prozent zunimmt dass das ist
natürlich so dass das nicht immer
bekannt ist und nicht immer eindeutig
wahrscheinlicher exposition sword die
leute waren an verschiedenen orten das
heißt da werden auch zum teil mehrere
erfasst mehrere länder ja und wir führen
auch eine liste die veröffentlichen wir
ja auch einmal der woche im lagebericht
wo wir zeigen was die wahrscheinlichen
infektions orte sind so die top ten
top-15 sind da enthalten und das sind im
moment in erster linie andere
europäische länder also aber
wahrscheinlich dort ist und bleibt
deutschland also das ist das aller
wahrscheinlichste und selbst wenn selbst
wenn jemand das einbringt und hier eben
dann positiv getestet wird dann ist es
das entscheidende der folge fälle zu
verhindern also da vorsichtig zu sein
die anzahl der folge fälle möglichst
gering zu halten und das kann man eben
machen indem man die anzahl seiner engen
kontakte möglichst gering hält
und dadurch haben wir es dann in der
hand also wirklich die anzahl unserer
engen kontakte so gering wie möglich zu
halten
die reisenden werden auch wieder
zunehmend jetzt wahrscheinlich natürlich
mit der rückreisewelle mit dem ende vom
urlaubs von der urlaubszeit wenn manchen
bundesländern auch eine rolle spielen
es sind aber nicht nur urlaubsreisende
das sind auch saison arbeite aber dann
ist es auch häufig schwierig zu
unterscheiden wo hat diese
infektionskrankheit stattgefunden wo
haben sie sich wirklich infiziert da
muss man sehr genau gucken sehr
differenziert gucken also wenn sie
irgendwo lesen das sind hier sein
ausbruch unter saison arbeiter dieser
oder jener nationalität dann heißt das
natürlich nicht unbedingt dass sie diese
jetzt aus ihrem heimatland mitgebracht
haben sondern möglicherweise haben sie
sich einfach hier vor ort angesteckt in
den lebensbedingungen wo sie ihm
arbeiten das ist das wahrscheinlichere
aktuell vielen dank wir noch ein
bisschen zeit dann können wir noch eine
zweite fragerunde beginnen mit wackelt
von reuters ich habe noch mal eine frage
auch zum thema urlaub spricht die
flugreisen da haben sich die
verkehrsminister darauf verständigt dass
man halt diesen mittel gang setzen kann
also im flugzeug kann man ja keine
abstandsregeln dann mal einhalten
wir sind mehrere hundert leute auf
engstem raum über mehrere stunden macht
ihnen das sorgen halten sie das für
gefährlich also die regeln wie im
flugzeug gesessen wird die werden ja von
den lokalen behörden und den
entsprechenden fluglinien vereinbart im
flugzeug ist die situation folgende das
unterscheidet das flugzeug von vielen
verkehrsmittel oder wahrscheinlich für
von allen anderen verkehrsmitteln in den
neuen flugzeugen also in den normalen
linienflugzeugen
dort herrscht ja eine gute lüftung und
die luft wird auch sehr häufig umgewälzt
und wird zudem auch noch mitspielt dann
gefiltert hepa filter das sind filter
die dafür sorgen dass zb so kleine
partikel viren herausgefiltert werden
insofern ist die reise in dem flugzeug
noch ein ort wo die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man sich ansteckt nicht so hoch ist
wenn wir auf die zahl gucken werden
glaube ich gerade gestern im krisen
würde ich darüber gesprochen
wir haben momentan noch nicht sehr viele
informationen darüber wie viele menschen
insgesamt in zusammenhang mit flugreisen
sich infiziert haben
das hängt zurzeit mit datenschutz
aspekten auch zusammen aber zumindest
ist es so dass wir ihn von den gesamten
fehlen die wir in deutschland haben nur
von sehr wenigen fällen sehen dass sie
mit reisen im flugzeug zusammenhängen
das ist die momentane aussage die wir
dazu treffen können kann ich vielleicht
noch kurz ergänzen wir hatten
zwischenzeitlich kontakte im flugzeug
nicht nachverfolgt in der hauptzeit der
pandemie anfangs ja dann hatten wir das
einige wochen eingestellt aufgrund der
insgesamten anpassung der lage und das
riesigen aufwand dass der damit
verbunden ist für die gesundheitsämter
ist es wahnsinnig anstrengend und
kompliziert die daten von diesen
fluggästen zu bekommen von den
internationalen airlines und diese
menschen in aller welt heraus zu finden
und dann zu informieren dass es sehr
sehr schwierig und gelingt auch nicht
immer und deswegen sind ist die
datenlage da auch brüchig wir wissen es
häufig auch nicht wie entweder werden
die leute nicht erreicht oder man
erfährt eben auch nicht was daraus
geworden ist
es gibt schon einzelberichte wo es zu
übertragen gekommen ist aber dass jetzt
zu quantifizieren ist sehr schwierig
kann man im moment noch nicht wirklich
machen die leute waren ja auch nicht nur
im flugzeug sie waren auch auf dem
flughafen sie haben auch andere
verkehrsmittel benutzt diese einem
anderen land gewesen in einem hotel
und wo hat dann die infektion wirklich
stattgefunden das ist bei einer
franken wie marco witt 19 ist das extrem
schwer herauszufinden wann hat diese
übertragung genau stattgefunden gerade
bei der situation die wir jetzt weltweit
haben denn es kann wie gesagt über all
sein
das heißt aber natürlich nicht dass wir
so auf die leichte schulter nehmen
können und wo immer möglich abstand
halten auch im flugzeug sonst mund nase
bedeckung tragen und eben auf distanz
achten vor rexroth wollen sie noch mal
klarstellen
diese einzelnen fälle die berichtet
wurden sind internationale fehler
es gibt eine fülle von deutschen sozial
genau das gibt internationale berichte
einige einzelne wohl froh dass mal auch
in publikationen ausgewertet wurde
wo leben die wahrscheinlich übertragung
flugzeug dann dokumentiert wurde die
wahrscheinliche man kann es immer nicht
mit letzter sicherheit sagen soll es
kindle zu frau wäber steinhaus wenn sie
noch mal sagen welche redaktion sie
vertreten
ja ich bin von der washington post ich
habe eine harke und zwar gibt es
irgendwie hinweise indikation dass die
sommer viele leichte verlaufen sind oder
anders laufen als die schule bisher also
ich kann für meinen teil sagen mir ist
das nicht bekannt
dazu ich kann vielleicht also wie schwer
die fälle verlaufen das hängt ja auch in
erster linie mit der demographischen
zusammensetzung zusammen sind das ältere
personen sind das menschen mit
vorerkrankungen und da können wir schon
sagen dass es zur hauptzeit der ersten
welle also hoffentlich der einzigen
welle in deutschland
so war das wir zeitweise sehr sehr viel
mehr fälle unter älteren und eben auch
um dann entsprechend vor erkrankten
menschen gesehen haben und dass die
zusammensetzung sich ein bisschen wieder
geändert hat also der anteil jüngerer
bevölkerungsgruppen ist wieder höher
geworden am anfang der pandemie war der
schon sehr hoch das waren die reisen
denn das waren die feier
das waren auch zum teil arbeits
ausbrüche und in der in der hoch-zeit
ist es dann leider eben in die alten und
pflegeheime in die krankenhäuser im
großen größerem maßstab eingetragen
wurden und da sind die wirklich vielen
schweren verläufe zu befürchten aber es
ist auch jetzt so in den familien gibt
es auch ältere und vor erkrankte und es
sind relativ viele aus ruhig jetzt auch
im zusammenhang mit familien und
familienfeiern und auch dort können
ältere und vor erkrankte menschen und
erkranken und auch schwer erkranken und
sterben
es ist so man sieht ist immer erst etwas
später und es ist auch so dass auch bei
coop 19 jüngere leute schwer erkranken
und sterben können es ist nicht so dass
sie nur weil sie jünger sind und keine
vorerkrankungen haben sich in sicherheit
wiegen können das können die kliniker
besser erzählen als wir
aber es ist auf jeden fall eine schwere
krankheit vor der man sich nach aller
möglichkeit schützen muss vielen dank
dann gehen wir noch mal zu bild frau die
ich habe von vielen kollegen auch gehört
dass eine große unsicherheit darüber
herrscht was man denn nach den urlaub
wenn man wieder nach hause kommt können
sie dann noch einmal drei goldene regeln
zusammenfassen urlaubs also die erste
also herzlichen dank dafür
für die frage also die erste goldene
regel ist sich im urlaub vernünftig zu
verhalten das möchte ich mal ganz
deutlich sagen es ist ja wirklich
wirklich irrelevant ob sie sich im
urlaub oder zu hause befinden
dort wo sie sind sollten sie diese aha
regeln beachten
wenn sie dann ja vermeiden die die zu
reduzieren das risiko wirklich sehr sehr
stark dass sie mit vielen personen
zusammenkommen und dann die chance
wächst dass einer davon eben infiziert
das heißt also der urlaub ist genauso
ein teil der vorsorge gegen eine
ausbreitung von kogit 19 wie ihr berufs-
und privatleben das ist wenn wenn wenn
das eine golden
regel ist dann ist es die aller aller
wichtigste goldene regel das setting ist
egal indem sie sind oder indem wir sind
wir sollten uns immer an diese regeln
halten
der zweite aspekt ist ja der schmutz der
momentan so dass diejenigen die aus
risikogebieten kommen sind ja
verpflichtet den quarantäne zu gehen 14
tage und das sollten sie eben auch tun
denn wenn sie sich angesteckt haben
sollten
in der quarantäne stecken sie niemanden
anders an das ist ja der sinn der
quarantäne darauf beruht die ganze
seuchenbekämpfung dass derjenige der
infiziert ist möglichst niemanden
anderen infiziert und die dritte goldene
regel dann hau ich hoffe ich sage ich
die richtigen und muss mich noch mal
verbessern die dritte goldene regel ist
jede person in unserem land die denkt
dass sie infiziert wäre dass sie krank
wäre die symptome von kogit 19 hat die
stehen ja alle in unserem steckbrief auf
der website sehr gut beschrieben
das sind teilweise symptome wie grippe
also schmerzen die der schmerzen
muskelschmerzen sind
atemwegserkrankungen
es ist der guru der verlust von geruchs
und geschmackssinn für bestimmte zeiten
jeder der sich krank fühlt sollte bitte
zu einem arzt gehen bzw den arzt anrufen
und möglichst sich testen lassen um
herauszufinden ob er krank ist oder
nicht ob ecofit 19 hat oder nicht
ich denke das sind die wesentlichen
regeln und sie sehen an diesen regeln
und das ist der kernpunkt dass jeder
einzelne dazu beitragen kann dass sich
diese krankheit nicht ausbreitet also
nochmal bitte unterscheiden sie nicht
zwischen dem ort wo sie sind wie sie
sich verhalten sondern halten sie diese
aha regel über allein wären noch eine
neue frage herr fällt wie strand trug
er fällt immer wieder
sie haben ja die wichtigkeit der abstand
jetzt auch noch mal gesagt hallo hallo
gehören sie ihr fell tisch
wie können sie höre jetzt also jetzt
allerdings nicht ihr problem gleich
nochmal
ich rufe so lange denn schreiber von afg
nochmal auf verschreibung er hat eine
kurze nachfrage zum thema masken zu
raten in geschlossenen räumen oder auch
im freien und wenn ja wohin
ja das ist eigentlich ganz einfach zu
beantworten also wir haben diese regeln
die aha regeln also abstand da sagen wir
dass man mindestens ein meter fünfzig
abstand halten sollte dann nehmen wir
die hände hygiene regeln das heißt also
dass man sich die hände regelmäßig
wäscht und dort wo es sinnvoll ist auch
desinfiziert und wenn man das nicht
machen kann also wenn man wenn es nicht
gelingt sicher diese ein meter fünfzig
abstand einzuhalten
immer dort empfehlen wir das tragen von
masken
also das ist wirklich eigentlich
gleichgültig ob das in einem raum ist
oder ob das außerhalb eines raumes also
im freien ist es kommt immer darauf an
wie viele menschen unterwegs sind und
mit wie vielen menschen man kontakt hat
das heißt das vermeiden von
menschenansammlungen das vermeiden von
zusammenkommen von vielen menschen ist
der wichtigste faktor weil das virus nur
dort eine chance haben kann auf einen
neuen wirt wir das sagen in dem fall ist
der wird also der mensch überzugehen
übertragen zu werden und das virus sich
dann in diesem neuen wird
vervielfältigen kann also diese regeln
gelten wirklich völlig unabhängig von
der location in der sie sind und wenn
sie drinnen sind und das wird natürlich
gerade im herbst auch einfach
mengenmäßig sich dann wieder da
verlagern
dann ist es noch wichtig dass mehr
zusetzt dafür sorge trägt dass die
belüftung sehr gut ist also das frische
luft da ist das luftaustausch
stattfindet dahinter ist die überlegung
ganz einfach
wenn jemand unter den anwesenden sein
sollte und das ist ja diese große
erkenntnis die wir im laufe des märz
gewonnen haben dass das virus auch schon
von vielen ausgeschieden wird bevor sie
überhaupt symptome haben das heißt man
ist noch gesund man fühlt sich noch
gesund und man kann es ja sein dass ein
solcher mensch in so einer gruppe ist
dann kann man dadurch die anzahl der
viren die in der luft sind übertragen
sind die kann man dadurch durch eine
gute lüftung durch gute lüftungssysteme
und im guten luftdurchsatz kann man die
reduzieren und dadurch reduziert man
dann natürlich auch die möglichkeit dass
sich jemand an steckt und noch mal diese
wirkung der mund nasen bedeckung das ist
ja auch ein ganz entscheidender punkt
steht die schützen einen selber in sehr
geringem maße
aber sie schützen eben wenn alle diese
mund nasen bedeckung tagen sehr viele
andere weil einfach wenn tröpfchen wenn
man spricht wenn man in der nähe von
jemandem ist und das virus wird schon
ausgeschiedenen bleiben natürlich teile
von diesen tröpfchen in diesen alltags
masken auch hängen und sie verbreiten
sie nicht so weit das ist das prinzip
der alltags massen und es wirkt nur dann
wenn alle diese masken tragen oder
diesem und nasen bedecken weil sie dann
die anderen mit schützen
wir probieren es noch mal mit herrn
fällt wie strand truppe zu schulen
möchte ich noch mal fragen mit vor allem
klassenstärken unterrichtet werden kann
den schwulen es gibt ja aber
bundesländer die das planen erreicht ist
aus ihrer sicht verantwortungsvoll dass
man klasse unterrichtet ich denke der
entscheidende moment ist der die die
planungen die die einzelnen schulen
machen also es ist wichtig dass man
klassen verbündet zusammenhält das heißt
also dass man die klassen nicht mischt
zum beispiel gibt es ja so was wie
leistungskurse verschiedene kursangebote
wo man im normalen schulalltag
tag dann schüler aus verschiedenen
jahrgängen teilweise auch mischt und das
ist sicher die wichtigste maßnahme dass
das unterbunden wird also dass man so
genannte epidemiologische einheiten
gründe bildet die dann eben nicht
zusammen kommen aber auch hier möchte
ich noch mal folgendes sagen das ist ja
auch nur ein teil der der aspekte der
zweite teil ist ja dann was machen die
schüler dann wenn sie aus der schule
heraus kommen wenn sie zu hause sind und
dann ist das natürlich genau die gleiche
punkt auch doch das natürlich sinnvoll
wenn sie sich dann eben nur möglichst
mit den schülerinnen und mitschülern
treffen mit denen sie auch in der schule
waren ja das heißt also diese ganze
problematik die möglichkeit dass ein
virus übertragen wird hängt damit
zusammen wie viele verschiedene menschen
in einer bestimmten zeit einer trifft
und das muss alles so gut wie möglich
reduziert werden
und das ist ein entscheidender punkt der
betrachtet werden muss
vielen dank wir haben es noch zwei
fragen die sozusagen der zweiten
fragerunde sind und dann sollte es auch
klappen
er will damit noch mal leise alte können
sie kaum vorstellbar dann versuche ich
jetzt ist alles versucht es nochmal es
werden aktuell sehr wenig todesfälle
berichtet es ja ausgesprochen erfreulich
liegt das nur daran dass die zahl der
infektionen zurück gegangen ist oder
liegt das auch daran dass die ärzte der
zwischenzeit mehr erfahrung haben und
die patienten besser behandelt
erfolgreicher behandeln können das ist
eine sehr gute frage wildermuth das ist
tatsächlich zum allergrößten teil darauf
zurückzuführen dass die infektionszahlen
runter geht
es wird morgen im lancet respiratory
diseases wird eine studie publiziert die
rund 10.000 patienten umfasst in dieser
studie werden sie die antwort auf ihre
frage glaube ich gut bekommen
der entscheidende punkt ist der in
deutschland gewesen und das ist der
punkt das ist die linie die wir auch
immer halten müssen und das ist darum
müssen wir uns nach wie vor eben an
dieser h
inhalten der entscheidende punkt war
dass wir in deutschland zu keiner zeit
nicht jeden patienten intensiv behandeln
konnten der das brauchte also auch zu
den hochzeiten der pandemie also wurde
die anzahl der patienten
ich glaube zur zeit haben wir noch etwa
100 also über 100 fälle 120 130 fälle
oder so haben wir meines wissens dass
das gm diese register heraus haben wir
momentan noch intensiv station
wir konnten zu jeder zeit alle patienten
optimal behandeln und es ist aber
trotzdem so das sind ja auch die zahlen
die wir hergeben
diejenigen unter den patienten die
beatmet werden mussten von denen sind
immer noch etwa 50 prozent verstorben
das heißt also die behandlung trotz sehr
guter behandlung und
intensivmedizinischer betreuung ist die
krankheit eine so schwerwiegende
krankheit das unter denjenigen die dann
wirklich auch auf intensiv kommen und
beatmet werden müssen die todesfälle
immer noch stark sind
ja es gibt zwei medikamente von denen
wir inzwischen wissen dass sie insgesamt
eine verbesserung aber kein durchbruch
aber eine verbesserung des ausgangs
bedingen können dass eine fremde sie wir
dass ein medikament was gegen viren
wirkt direkt da sehen wir das war den
verlauf bei leichten fällen bei
mittelschweren fällen voll kürzen können
und dexamethason das ist ein medikament
das die immunantwort des körpers die
entzündungsreaktion etwas herunter
reguliert da wissen wir inzwischen dass
wenn dieses dexamethason zu einem späten
schweren verlauf zeitung gegeben wird
dass es tatsächlich dazu führen kann
dass die die die die die todeszahlen
insbesondere runtergehen und das ist das
sind beides also dass rim dexamethason
wurde natürlich auch vorher schon war
von von psychologen verwendet bei
schweren atemwegsinfektion das heißt
also die aktuell geringen zahlen liegen
an den geringen fallzahlen die
infektionen
jetzt noch halb weg.de ich als sorge ich
habe er hat nicht gesenkt reiseleiter
prima danke dann können wir noch mal
kurz ein zelt fragen der hatte noch
keine nachfrage
ja ich möchte mal andere frage zu
stellen
durch die frage der testung wie sehen
ihre empfehlung da aus zum beispiel
schulen die bei positiven fällen an der
klasse weitere schüler und lehrer nicht
testen wenn mindestens ein meter fünfzig
abgehalten wurde und kein enger kontakte
über längere zeit von dem schüler
passierte aber kann man das tatsächlich
sagen dass eine übertragung sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist auch wenn man den
ganzen tag immer mit klasse zusammen
gesessen so die möglich die konkreten
konzepte die gemacht werden die obliegen
ja wirklich den lokalen behörden vor ort
die das zusammen mit den schulen machen
und es gibt in deutschland
hunderttausende schulen und es gibt ganz
verschiedene schulklassen ganz
verschiedene technische ausstattung von
schulen auch lüftungs ausstattung es ist
wirklich eine frage die man so pauschal
nicht beantworten kann was aber ganz
wichtig ist und das ist der teil der
ihrer frage der den ich für jetzt noch
mal ganz ganz relevant beantworten
möchte dass der entscheidende punkt ist
der dass man signale einer krankheit
sehr schnell erkennt das heißt also dass
man sehr schnell reagiert und dann eben
sehr schnell testet und zu den ganzen
hygiene konzepten die wir von den
schulen erwarten dass sie die
unmittelbar nach schulbeginn wieder
einsetzen gehört natürlich auch nicht
test strategie das heißt also wenn es so
sein sollte dass menschen sei als lehrer
oder schüler oder auch andere
angestellte der schulen positiv scheine
klinische erscheinung haben dann müssen
die recht schnell getestet werden
und natürlich müssen sie sofort selber
in quarantäne gehen damit sie keine
anderen anstecken das auch ein ganz
wichtiges moment
ich habe oft auch das gefühl in die
diskussion dass menschen sagen okay man
ist getestet man es negativ getestet
dann hat man quasi ein sicherheitsgefühl
ich bin negativ ich habe die krankheit
nicht aber das ist nur eine
momentaufnahme kann
am nächsten tag kann der test ja auch
positiv sein das heißt der entscheidende
punkt ist der dass wenn man sich krank
fühlt dass man so schnell wie möglich
eben in quarantäne geht und sich dann
testen lässt um im falle dessen dass man
infiziert war keine anderen anzustecken
also hygiene konzept mit einer guten
test strategie und der verfügbarkeit von
tests und der schnellen verfügbarkeit
von testergebnissen das ist das ist das
entsprechende was man überall voll
aussetzen muss und was überall
funktionieren muss in der zukunft
vielen dank wir haben noch zwei jetzt
auf der liste der g noch eine zweite
frage stellen und dann wird die liste
auch geschlossen
frau weber steinhaus hatten sie noch
eine frage oder nur vergessen die hand
zu heben und als letztes dann planet
interview
ja danke ich hatte tatsächlich noch zwei
fragen das eine schließt ein bisschen an
die letzte antwort an
zum thema ok stadionbesuche da gab es
einen fußballverein der vorgeschlagen
hatte alle seine fenstern zu testen und
die danone mindestabstand ins stadion zu
lassen
was halten sie davon ja gesagt diese
strategien sind sind lokale überlegungen
das müssen die behörden aber genehmigen
ja das heißt also die überlegungen von
einzelnen sind nur dann letztlich
operativ wenn die behörden das
genehmigen
ich kann nur folgendes sagen die a-ha
regeln sind der schlüssel zum erfolg um
diese pandemie eingrenzen zu können und
zu den aha regeln gehören ein meter
fünfzig abstand händehygiene und da wo
wir ein meter fünfzig abstand handy
gehen nicht einhalten können
das tragen von mund nasenschutz oder
alltags masken
vielen dank das war ein schönes
schlusswort wir bedanken uns bei allen
zuhören oder zuschauern und
vielleicht irgendwann bis zum nächsten
mal bis dahin
ok
[Musik]